there has been a lot of chatter about
the state of cnn with our own joe
conscious saying the network's collapse
is now complete but cnn hosts doing
their best to send a different message
this place is not perfect
it will never be perfect
we will always have flaws we will always
screw up we will always have to run
corrections we will always have to keep
working to make it better and better and
better every single day that is the goal
we lost our leader this week
but we're not going anywhere
joining us live with his take is fox
news contributor joe concha joe why do
you disagree with uh stelter
well again he's an impressive fellow to
run the whole public relations unit and
or on opposition research that division
and to run the crisis management
division as well and to be the cnn media
correspondent wearing all those hats at
once
is impressive why do i disagree with
them because the network truly is
collapsing now at this point guys
because considering what has happened
recently right it's network president
jeff zucker he's been there for about
the past decade he was forced out
abruptly
on an excuse by the way that zero people
in the country believe because of a
consensual relationship i mean even with
the network president resigning the the
network is lying to its viewers because
because you know it was much more than
that given all the reports we're seeing
as far as zucker and his girlfriend
allison gullist advising andrew cuomo on
how to hit donald trump on covet at the
height of a pandemic while making cuomo
look good and then getting all the
ratings they got out of it by arranging
all those interviews between andrew
cuomo and chris cuomo at the time so
yeah that that's laughable that that's
the excuse that why jeff sucker's out
but also it's top-rated anchor the man i
just mentioned chris cuomo and i get
that top-rated anchor over at cnn means
skinniest kid at fat camp but cuomo also
out recently so their biggest star is
gone but most importantly from a
business perspective they have lost 90
percent of their audience when compared
to the same time last year now imagine
that 10 people are in a room carly right
they're watching cnn one year ago nine
have left the room so business is
horrible it has no leader and this is
the state of cnn at this point which has
no credibility and certainly is not the
network that i watched growing up during
the two gulf wars where they're
reporting and their objectivity was
something really to behold it was a
great great network now it is a shell of
itself it has collapsed what stood out
to me so much was the absolute loyalty
the employees the people on air had to
jeff zucker because it told me that they
too believe that they should only be a
trump-bashing fox-bashing january 6th
exploding network and that shocked me
because that's not what cnn used to be
one quickly get to this espn panelist
says u.s has no room to criticize
genocide in china joe when i saw this i
said cue concha let's cue this tape
all right
who are we to criticize china's human
rights records when we have ongoing
attacks by the agents of the state
against unarmed citizens and we've got
assaults on the voting rights so sports
i think it is possible and it's
necessary more than ever to just shut
everything out if you are to enjoy the
actual games themselves and not only did
espn not censure that they promoted that
clip are people like adande people at
espn2 stupid to understand the dangers
of china or too ignorant of what exactly
is in the republican voting preservation
bills joe
todd we love sports we talked about just
now how cnn used to be a great network
espn was as well right particularly
during the 90s and olbermann and patrick
and and just what espn was was escapism
and now this is what it's become it's
almost impossible to differentiate espn
from msnbc or the view at this point and
by the way here's a news flasher j.a
adande who says wait uh we we have
voting issues here and that compares to
what's happening with the uyghurs as far
as slave labor uh here's the news flash
three and four americans support voter
id requirements in this country
including a majority of african-american
voters you want to go into any espn
building you need a photo id but of
course nothing's gonna happen here to
adande he'll probably be promoted and be
the next anchor of sports center because
this is what's embraced at espn but if
you're conservative over there you're
showing the door quickly for sharing any
sort of political view it's quite
hilarious on some level okay joe concha
live for us this morning on a monday
thanks joe i'm steve ducey i'm brian
killme and i'm ainsley earhart and click
here to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis